Summer in Japan is too hot, just wipe off the sweat, sweat again It's too hot, I
need air conditioning too It's too hot, I want to get on the main train
No, I'm crying because it hurts It's too hot I can't
keep up with the publication It's too hot and ice
cream is just ice cream
It's
too hot, I forgot the next line It's too hot, and
the fireworks are seen from inside the room It's too hot,
the dehumidifier looks like a box of contracts
File Hey, forever
insurance is too much for the guards name, so
I made it into a video again
It's so hot I
'm wearing only pants It's too
hot I don't want to support the hot springs in my new house Even
though it was really expensive
I want to drink fake coffee from a vending machine too It's too hot sometimes too early
Easter spinning greetings on the side too
eo
Suzu City It's
too hot to become a real
Michishita  The summer in Japan, when I became Panman, is too hot, and
during that time, I
'm not good at speaking Japanese when I'm using
clichés about foreigners.